Nine hundred million dollars.
That's how much organizers of next year's Tokyo Olympic Games are spending...
...to keep athletes and spectators safe from spreading coronavirus.
The figure was revealed on Tuesday...
...as part of the latest budget for the delayed games,...
...taking the games' total cost to 15.4 billion dollars.
Those COVID-19 countermeasures were included in the extra 2.8 billion dollars...
...allocated to cover the cost of postponing from this year because of the pandemic.
Prime Minister Yoshihide Suga's government has declared he will host the Olympics at any cost...
...and is pressing ahead with preparations.
Tokyo Olympics chief executive Toshiro Muto...
...repeated the commitment to keeping the Olympics safe.
Countermeasures will include a PCR testing infrastructure and setting up a designated clinic.
Some of the extra cost will be covered by additional sponsorship and insurance...
...organizers previously said this month.
They would also tap a contingency fund detailed in last year's budget...
...to cover some costs.